prendre un rendez vous avec un médecin
un véritable casse tête pour les
franciliens
en ile-de-france la population a accès à
moins de 2,5 consultations par an par
habitant
c'est deux fois moins que la moyenne
nationale un problème qui en entraîne un
autre
l'engorgement des hôpitaux et surtout d
urgence les urgences ou encombrés par
des malades qui viennent directement
parce qu'ils ont plus de médecins
généralistes et aujourd'hui il ya des
médecins qui partent parce qu'ils ont
une telle pression de continuité des
soins sur l'hôpital qui peuvent pas
tenir jeu contient un service où il y
aurait besoin de quatre ou cinq médecins
et qu'on met un poste qui va le prendre
ce but là pour se taper le tsunami de
malades personne et j'ai des collègues
qui baisse les bras je peux vous dire
parce qu'ils savent très bien que les
malades sont pas soignés correctement
alors pour stopper l'hémorragie
certaines communes prennent le relais à
ce temps la mairie finance un centre
municipal de santé qui emploie 35
praticiens 30000 actes médicaux ils sont
pratiqués chaque année des conditions de
travail et de soins plus confortable qui
permet un suivi régulier des patients
on peut s'attarder un petit peu plus sur
le côté psychologique sur le côté
relationnel et ne pas simplement faire
les actes de soins comme comme à
l'hôpital et a beaucoup de personnes
âgées
du coup elle préfère se déplacer si il
ya des habitués donc ils connaissent 109
santé depuis plusieurs années
mais une initiative qui a un coût élevé
pour cette commune de 40000 habitants 3
millions d'euros par an et un centre de
soins qui peinent aussi à recruter le
manque de médecins
je pense moi je l'expliquent par le
numerus clausus 6 en moins de médecins
dans qu'il ya moins de prescriptions qui
dit moins de prescriptions 20 des
dépenses
donc je pense qu'il faut enlever quand
même le numerus clausus et
voilà il libérer un poulain mais ce que
le numerus clausus sera supprimée à
partir de la rentrée 2020 mais il faudra
encore attendre que cette nouvelle
génération de médecins soient formés au
total les études de médecine dure neuf
ans
[Musique]